uh gentlemen uh let me start by saying
the season 2 teaser trailer I just
watched looks fantastic that looks
really good so I don't know I think it's
Eight Episodes the second season yeah
that's correct so of the Eight Episodes
which are you most looking forward to
Fan seeeing like like is it episode 6 is
it episode 4 there's a couple episodes
for me in in uh the middle that I'm I'm
really curious to the reaction but I
think the biggest one I can't wait for
people to see is just one just because
the new tone the new feel um everything
um I'm just curious to see how people
react to to the newness of this season
yeah episode one certainly because um
you know the introduction for me of my
character and to to invite people into
that world and for them to see it and
then I I would say as well for me
episode 3 just because that uh again for
Akerson there's just an insight into his
character there you know a bit of a more
of a personal Insight which I'm uh I'm
really excited to see how that spins
people's opinion after seeing the first
two episodes uh is episodes three where
you touch a certain
artifact I may or may not touch a
certain artifact at any point during the
it's in the
trailer don't be touching my artifact
boy you keep your hands off my artifact
keep your hands off
my just throw Hey listen I'm only asking
what I saw in the footage one of the
things I really enjoyed about season one
was you guys had some really good action
set pieces and the trailer that we just
saw uh teases some pretty crazy action
set pieces so I know it's all about the
characters and character Journeys but I
know as well but fans also love when
you're kicking ass so what what can you
tease about the action uh personally I
mean I just think the action if it if
you liked it last year that's or season
one that's great I think it's far
superior in season two and for me the
reason why it's far superior is that it
it puts you in the action rather than
standing back and letting you watch it
it feels much more visceral it feels
much more engaging it feels like you're
a part of the battle and that's all done
through camera work and camera movement
and for me it's just uh it's a much
better tonal match for for the show uh
what can you actually tease and I I hate
asking the generic thing but like what
can you actually tease a little bit more
about your character and how perhaps
villain antagonist protagonist like
where is he on the chart first of all I
think uh everyone's the hero of Their
Own Story so I think aers you know in
his mind is certainly not a villain and
he prioritizes the greater good of
humanity so I think everything he does
through the whole course of the show is
because he believes he genuinely
believes it's the right thing to do and
there will be sacrifices along the way
but those are necessary
sacrifices got it
antagonist no I mean I'll chime in on
that because uh you know one of the one
of the joys of of season 2 and watching
season 2 is not just Joseph's
performance but getting to see um how
Akerson is spooled out you know uh he's
introduced as what we sort of feels like
a traditional villain and then I think
as the season goes on and on there's
depth that's added layer by layer that
makes you uh feel differently uh piece
by piece well a great villain though or
a great antagonist is someone who can
justify what they're doing and
demonstrate to the audience like maybe
this is
the right path to go on so you
understand why they did it even if you
don't agree with it yeah absolutely yeah
and I I did I you know it was a gift of
a a wonderful Arc written for me in in
the show which allowed that you know so
yeah I'm very grateful for that I'm
curious also about season 2 and how it
expands the mythology of Halo and um you
know what can you sort of talk about
that in terms of the mythology not much
I'll be honest but um but you know one
of the one of the uh keys to this season
is that um it's it's darker in a way
that uh and in order to get that
Darkness or in order to hit that
Darkness um there's a lot of loss that
happens um and so characters are going
to interact with this loss uh in a way
that um is different for each of them
and it's a it's a massive loss that I
think we all might be aware of in uh
necessarily sacrifices are made uh for
both of you you see the shooting
schedule uh what is a day you have
circled in terms of I cannot wait to
shoot this or oh my God I can't believe
we have to shoot this I just loved to be
on set there so I every day that I could
be there doing these scenes with these
great actors and working with uh the
producers and writers like David our
showrunner would be on set and and we'd
be working you know it's such a a huge
budget show but we'd be working like a
little theater troop you know refining
the scene running it how does this work
let's cut these lines let's rearrange
the like up until the very last moment
we're we're working to make it feel
organic and feel natural and it was so
exciting to me so you know I every
chance I got I'd Circle all the days I
can't wait to to get it done you know uh
for me after the experience of season
one uh I I knew how challenging the the
battle sequences were to shoot uh in
terms of doing stunts while in the
costume I I quickly made sure that the
stunt guys were going to be doing all of
those for season
two uh and but then there you know I
something would come up on the call
sheet where there were some stunts that
would happen where I I'm not in the suit
and those I knew I I couldn't get away
with not doing so I had those circled as
as things that were going to be
challenging well I mean I think listen I
don't think people realize also what a
marathon it is to make a television show
and the hours that go on to make
something like this it's not I mean
they're long hours it's long days and
it's not just a set schedule so you know
one day you're shooting 14 hours through
the day and then I think there was about
six weeks of nights on this season
there's all sorts of shifts in your
schedule as well so yeah it's it's
certainly uh challenging we shot Eight
Episodes I was there for a year that
that's exactly you've just demonstrated
to give you an indication right so now
that you've done season two yeah uh it's
pretty clear that um maybe the studio
might want a season three just throwing
that out there so how much are you in
your brain in terms of already mentally
because it it's a huge commitment
especially for your family blocking out
the next five or 10 years yeah perhaps
uh who knows let's see let's let's leave
all of those questions to other people
uh be happy to make more if uh if more
is oh yeah what's on the calendar other
than that uh we'll just wait for
February 8th and see how everybody
receives it exactly so this is a
spoiler-free question but I'm still
going to ask it when season 2 ends what
do you think fans will be thinking give
me more yeah hopefully give me more give
me
more and kind of like oh
but in a good way you know so my
last thing for you cuz I'm just about
out of time if when you think about the
shoot of season 2 what's the day that
you think you'll always remember in
terms of like something you know one of
those crazy days on set or just a great
day with friends to me I I'll I'll I'll
go first uh the days that I'll remember
you know whether we shoot more Halo or
don't shoot more Halo for season one and
season two is the camaraderie of of
working with the people that we worked
with we had um almost every Saturday
night we would we would gather and do
karaoke uh in a little basement uh bar
right next to the the building I lived
in in season one and it was just
fantastic you know to get to because we
work so hard you spend so much time and
so much energy uh and it's so physical
and tough for everybody and to get to
blow steam off at the end of the week
with the people that you're working with
for me is just one of the great joys of
getting to do what I do yeah I mean so
so many of the days but certainly my
first day I I would will always remember
because it was just such a big day uh a
challenging day for me in terms of the
the amount of dialogue they threw you
right in they threw me into the deepend
and uh and you know in front of all all
of this cast and and it was just I mean
it was just such a tremendous experience
it it just kind of went so well and
everyone was so generous you know just
welcome to Halo here's a three-page
monologue yeah that's what it was and
and yeah it was kind of terrifying but
then elating as well to to to feel like
Oh I'm a part of this thing and these
people really care about this thing and
we're doing this together and you know
and to see how Pablo led by example on
on the set you know and as soon as as I
saw that I thought okay this is going to
be great a great eight months of nine
months you know and it really was but
yeah I'll never forget that first
day